welcome to the show everybody you know I
want to talk about this straight Pride
Parade that's happening in Boston but
before we before we get to that let's
begin with a word from big token big
token is a new app that lets you share
data about yourself about your interests
your habits and and then get paid for it
okay so it's nothing nothing is for free
at least nothing should be free
especially the data that you share about
yourself right now you know you already
share an enormous amount of information
with tech companies and they make money
off of it but you don't so that needs to
be changed and that's where big token
comes in here's how it works you first
you download the app you sign up for a
free big token account I've downloaded
it myself it's real quick real easy to
do so there's no reason not to do it
next you complete actions to earn points
your actions include answering surveys
checking into locations connecting your
social accounts and more and then you
can redeem your points for rewards such
as cash gift cards you could donate your
earnings to charity if you're a generous
sort of person personally you know I
choose the cash but that's just me I'm a
capitalist you choose what data you
share with big token and then you get
paid for it the surveys in the app will
ask general questions about your
demographic your your lifestyle specific
follow-up questions based on what you
answered on those questions and they're
also surveys about specific holidays or
events big token has other special or
other social features like in-app
messaging with your friends creating a
team to answer questions and earn more
you can also get more points for
referring friends and family your data
is always secured in big token based on
the data you choose to share you will be
placed in the specific groups and brands
will buy access to those to those ad
groups for use in personalized
advertising the best part again to
emphasize is that you get paid if you
want to start earning money for your
data go to the App Store or Google Play
search for big token that's b.i.g tio
que en that's one word don't download
the app and then sign up for there make
sure to use my referral code which is
matt walsh again search big token in the
app App Store or Google Play download
the
and use my referral code Matt Walsh to
sign up claim your data and get paid
okay so I will say that personally I
agree for the most part with the people
who say that the upcoming straight Pride
Parade maybe you heard about in Boston
is is silly you know I agree that it's
it's a silly thing it's not something
that I would be personally interested in
attending though I do appreciate some of
the you know I appreciate the especially
the intentional irony of my leon milo
gianopolous being the being the Grand
Marshal of the parade he's of course
very openly gay and yet he's leading the
straight Pride Parade which is kind of a
tongue-in-cheek move by the organizers
and I appreciate that you know I do but
I think overall it's a silly thing and I
think I am on stable intellectual ground
in calling the parade silly because I
have also said the same thing about gay
pride parades in fact in my opinion I
think parades in general are kind of
stupid
I don't get the I don't get the
attraction to parades of any kind really
parades are basically festive traffic
jams that's what they are especially if
you go to a if you've ever been to a
small town parade where they don't even
have floats or anything and for most the
most part that the parade mostly
consists of just local business owners
riding their company vans you know
through the parade so yeah you really
are just watching traffic go by and
people sit there for two hours and just
watch the traffic go by and I don't you
know I don't get it I personally don't
get it but I will acknowledge that there
are some justifiable reasons to throw a
parade okay like if you win a war okay
you throw a parade if you win a Super
Bowl
you throw a parade the point is if we're
going to have a parade to announce our
pride in something it should be
something that we actually accomplished
it should be an achievement of some sort
well then it makes
to have a parade or if not an
achievement it should be a holiday you
know an actual day of celebration like a
Thanksgiving parade or a Christmas
parade but your sexual orientation is
not an achievement neither is it a
holiday okay you haven't accomplished
anything simply by being attracted to
one sex or another and the thing is the
the you know LGBT folks they're the ones
who insist that being gay is not a
choice it's biological you were born
that way well then that's even more
reason not to have a Pride Parade
because it's just if it's something
you're born with and you might as well
have a parade you know a right handy a
right you know a right hand or a parade
though you're proud of the fact that
you're right-handed it's just if that's
the case it makes even less sense you
might as well have a parade for people
with brown eyes I mean what's what's the
point now it's argued of course that the
real purpose of a gay pride parade is to
resist and protest and stand up against
the persecution of homosexuals
heterosexuals are not persecuted for
being heterosexual as the argument goes
so therefore a heterosexual Pride Parade
is pointless but there is a point to the
gay pride parade but if that's the point
of a gay pride parade then why do we
call it a pride parade if it's really a
protest then why don't we call it a
protest or a rally or a demonstration
you know but you don't hear that they
don't they don't say it's a Gay Pride
protest they say it's a gay pride parade
and if it is a protest why do they hold
these quote protests in places like San
Francisco and Los Angeles and New York
rather than Iran or Saudi Arabia it
seems that these pride parades are held
in precisely the places where gays are
not persecuted so all of the evidence
indicates that gay pride parades are
indeed gay pride parades that is they
are parades that give gay people the
opportunity to announce their pride in
being gay
you know if you go to the New York City
pride parade website it calls their
pride parade a pride celebration there's
another LGBT website that's that says
you know gay people should quote feel
pride in being gay so that that puts it
pretty plainly and if you agree that
gays should feel pride in being gay if
gays should feel pride in their gayness
and that parades ought to be held across
the country to celebrate that pride and
to you know create these spaces for
self-expression for gay people or
whatever then it's obviously ludicrous
too and it's a double standard to insist
that heterosexuals aren't entitled to a
similar celebration what you know
straight people why aren't they entitled
to a celebration of their straightness
that's up in the double standard becomes
even more pronounced and obvious when
you take into account the whole as we
talked about last week you've got this
whole buffet of sexual orientations that
have now attached themselves like
barnacles to the broader LGBT ship so
gay men and lesbian women aren't the
only one only ones celebrating their
sexual orientation
there are also bisexuals and
transsexuals and pansexuals and asexuals
and gray sexuals and demisexuals and
gender-fluid people and gender
questioning people is it reasonable to
say that all of these people can and
should publicly declare their pride but
not heterosexuals I mean is it
reasonable to say that all of those
people yeah yeah sure but gay people
they got a pride lesbians have pride
asexuals have pride transsexual pet all
of them but no not straight people no
you're not supposed to have pride and
going back to the persecution thing if
this is really about persecution then
why are we including pansexuals I mean
when was the last time a pansexual was
persecuted have you have you ever heard
of a ban never have you ever seen a sign
up on a business somewhere saying
pansexuals not allowed get out of here
you pansexuals now I wouldn't know how
to persecute a pansexual if I wanted to
I you know if I went out looking for a
pansexual to persecute
I wouldn't be able to do it so no again
this is not about persecution this is
about boasting of your sex life and then
if that's the case then why can't
straight people boast just the same now
as I said I'm not in favor of anyone
boasting about this sort of thing but
I'm even less in favor of arbitrary
rules that allow some people to boast
while telling other people to keep quiet
the double standard the inconsistency to
me is the worst thing I hate that more
than anything else and the left is
famous for making rules like that and so
maybe on second thought the straight
Pride Parade is a little bit more than a
silly stunt maybe the point is simply to
defy the less rules just for the sake of
defying them why are they doing the
straight Pride Parade well because
because they're not supposed to I guess
maybe that's the point and if that's the
point then you know maybe there could be
some value in it after all even though I
still wouldn't go myself see the message
that the left has been sending to
straight white males for years now has
been you're not allowed to take pride in
anything while everyone else celebrates
their sexuality and their race and their
culture and their heritage and their
history you aren't allowed to celebrate
anything about yourself if you do you're
a homophobe or you're a racist or you're
a you know your ethnocentric or whatever
no the only thing you're allowed to feel
about yourself is guilt and shame that's
been the message for decades and
eventually you know people get tired of
it
people get tired of the guilt and the
shame people get tired of the the double
standards I think it's as simple as that
there's been a lot of discussion
recently about radicalization especially
the radicalization of young white
heterosexual men now much of what
media calls radicalization is really
just people deciding that they're
conservative and that's not
radicalization that's just someone
exploring ideas and coming to
conclusions and forming opinions there's
nothing radical about that but there is
some actual radicalization going on I
acknowledge that there are radical
groups there are radical there's a
radical fringe out there on both sides
where indeed especially on the right you
have angry young white men who end up in
these these groups that that is
happening
maybe the straight Pride Parade is an
example of that I don't know I don't
know a lot about the group that's
holding this thing I have no idea but
whatever radicalization is perhaps we
should consider the possibility that
young white men are becoming radicalized
in part because of the guilt and the
shame and the blame that is constantly
heaped on them by the culture they are
born the villains they are born into an
identity that the culture tells them is
tainted and while everyone else is told
to celebrate their identity
these men are told the opposite to
apologize and repent and feel guilt and
after a while it wears on you and you
you know you take these men you add in
on top of the shame and the guilt from
the culture all you on top of all the
cultural situation you add in a lack of
good male role models in the home a lack
of a attentive fathers perhaps you add
in a school system that caters to girls
while you know telling boys that they're
diseased and have ADHD or whatever but
just because they act like boys take all
those factors together it's not hard to
see how some of these guys go down the
radical path but and that's not making
excuses or anything like that that's
trying to understand how we ended up
where we are now and why people make
the choices they make and if you the
left loves to complain about angry white
mellow they're angry white men angry
what have you ever stopped it like what
are they angry about have you stopped to
consider that does it I mean you don't
want them to be angry have you just
stopped for a second to think but what
are they angry about and the thing is
even when you everything I'm saying now
they're gonna be people who respond oh
yeah sure straight what straight white
males are persecuted first yeah whatever
see that attitude is exactly the problem
I'm not saying I'm not talking about
persecution this is not you know that
that's not the word I'm using but shame
and guilt yeah there's just no question
about that that is a fact it's just a
fact in our culture that if you are a
straight white male you are told to feed
you you are there is shame and guilt
heaped on you from a young age it's just
that's that's called whatever you want
to call it but that's what happens and
it has a negative effect on people
that's the lesson here so maybe leftist
could consider that what you're doing
it's not working the white guilt thing
it's it is having the opposite effect
from what you intend it's not causing
white people to be more open and
tolerant everything it's not it doesn't
it doesn't people don't work that way
that doesn't work but we're not allowed
to talk about this of course when
discussing the real or perceived sins of
young white men the only thing we're
allowed to do is blame them and and so
the cycle the cycle continues
all right let's on a somewhat related
note here let's check in with Jack
Phillips and masterpiece cake shop now
this is a sort of the neverending saga
and let's I'm going to read now from a
daily wire report just published on the
site yesterday
it says masterpiece cake shop is again
under fire now the subject of a third
discrimination lawsuit alleging that
owner Jack Phillips discriminated
stay customer by refusing to make a cake
for an unspecified offense Phillips of
course one is for the United States
United States Supreme Court after suing
the Colorado Human Rights Commission
that punished him for refusing to
provide a wedding cake for a same-sex
wedding in Denver
the latest skipping ahead a little bit
the latest lawsuit was filed Wednesday
in Denver District Court on behalf of
autumns Gardena by attorneys Paul
Greeson and John McHugh scar Deena is
the same woman I believe actually this
is a quote trans woman's as a man we're
talking about who filed the previous
lawsuit alleging discrimination after
masterpiece cake shop deny her request
for a cake celebrating gender transition
then the reports on the newest lawsuit
are vague on the theme of the pastry in
question they've said so far only that's
Gardena request a birthday cake but
previous filings and indicate that scar
Deena has gone out of her way on several
occasions to request cakes that massive
piece of cake shop clearly would not
make okay so this is I guess the
specifics of this this is the third
lawsuit now against this is the third
time that the LGBT Lobby has come after
Jack Phillips third time I mean the the
the bullies that went after him now we
can't really say that he won in the
Supreme Court he didn't lose so the fact
that he didn't lose maybe as you could
say is a victory but certainly the the
bullies that were going after him
especially the Human Rights Commission
they lost they got scolded by the
Supreme Court for for targeting Jack
Phillips and for having clear
anti-christian bias so that was the
first one then this autumn scar Deena
character so again I believe is a is a
man because this was someone who wanted
a you wanted a cake to celebrate his
gender transition into a woman filed a
lawsuit over that and now we have
another and I guess apparently another a
different cake that this person wanted
but if this is
this is this is a troubled person who
has been harassing Jack Phillips for
months there are some one finds that
some of the details of the other cakes
that this person wanted Newsweek reports
that the baked goods at the center of
scar Dena's previous complaints to
Colorado authorities included a cake to
celebrate Satan's birthday with quote
cheesecake frosting that would feature a
large figure of Satan licking a 9-inch
black dildo an actual working model that
can be turned on before we unveil the
cake okay okay so this is a person
that's one of the cakes that Scardino
requested and that was turned down
wanted a gender transition cake which
isn't even a thing right I mean that's
not a gender transit like so you got a
gen a gender transition which by the way
is impossible there's no such thing as a
gender transition
you can't transition from one gender to
another so but I you know I can't
continue doing the scare quotes around
every word that I use when talking about
this case so just just fill in the scare
quotes yourself
she had a he had a gender transition
cake which is just not not really even a
thing obviously a cake that he came up
with because he wanted to be turned down
then you've got a cake for Satan's
birthday and then another cake this is
somebody is harassing Jack Phillips this
is harass this is anti-christian
harassment the only reason why this
bully keeps going after Jack Phillips is
because he knows that Jack Phillips is a
Christian that's the only reason
so the lawsuit should be the other way
the discrimination is happening the
other way with this case there's just no
basis to this whatsoever
this is a completely baseless
discrimination complaint and anyone who
takes it seriously is knows what they're
doing knows they're being dishonest and
by the way that the
applies also to the original lawsuit
that got all this going in the first
place
I just don't believe that those two gay
men who came to jack phillips looking
for a cake for their gay wedding
i just don't believe that it was a
coincidence that they happened to go to
jack phillips who was known as a devout
christian and who was known as someone
who turned down cakes if he didn't want
to do them on religious grounds he
turned down halloween cakes and other
cakes like that you know raunchy you
know bachelorette party or bachelor
party cakes who turned those he was
known for doing that and these two gay
men just happened to pick him as the guy
to make their gay wedding cake and when
he turned them down they just so
happened to be ready you know they had
the lawyer on standby they went through
the Human Rights Commission yeah okay
that was it sure right it was just
totally an innocent and coincidental I'm
sure no this is all it was a setup from
the beginning this is a setup to they
they won't leave them alone and this is
how the LGBT lobby operates if they get
you in their sights they will not leave
you alone they will just keep coming
after you and keep coming after you the
LGBT lobby these are the biggest bullies
in America these are some of the most
vicious people in America and when I say
that I am talking about the LGBT Lobby
these left-wing gay activists
specifically I'm not talking about gay
people in general I'm talking about
people like autumns autumns Gardena and
the the two gay men that came after
phillips originally those those people
that go out prowling on the lookout for
christians that they can entrap and then
try to ruin their life it is vengeful
vicious cruel these people are bullies
and nothing more all right before we get
to your emails we need to talk briefly
well I guess we don't need to talk about
this but we will these videos have been
popping up online recently they are
absolutely
terrifying and I'm sorry I have to
subject you to this but III do have to
share a couple of them with you just
because I had to see it so that means
you have to see it as well so first
watch this my God my God but it it it
gets worse okay so but watch watching
this one
[Music]
[Applause]
okay you know I changed my mind actually
white people are bad I it turns out that
yeah okay you know what down with white
people that is just that is a that is a
that's a vision of hell right there that
I I mean I imagine that walking up to
the gates of hell is like that you just
walk up the gates of hell you see that
that's how you're greeted by a gaggle of
white sorority girls in matching
t-shirts chanting they're witches spell
at you
it is bone-chilling stuff and I and it
only further supports my view which I've
held for a long time that sororities and
fraternities are cults that are always
just one step away from Jonestown and
and and if you want proof that mean that
you have exhibit wanted to write they're
really really terrifying all right let's
go to let's try to get away from that
and try to you know erase that from our
minds as quickly as we can we'll go to
emails Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com here's a here's
a long one but I love emails like this
kind of someone describing their
intellectual journey or I guess as the
media would put it this is a story of
radicalization so let me read this one
this is from Chris says hello lord and
savior future a theocratic dictator of
this world my name is Chris I am a 19
year old Chilean conservative male
living in Canada I redeemed myself to
your wisdom today to get some insight
into two main questions to which I can't
seem to answer myself since I do not
possess your intellectual capacity great
beginning I used to be an atheist
socialist left-wing pro-abortion psycho
since I used to think that if my
girlfriend got pregnant I would like to
be able to get rid of that
responsibility to which abortion is very
convenient after listening to one of Ben
Shapiro's anti-abortion videos in which
he shows the picture of a baby and says
this is a little game for the left where
in this picture is it okay to murder
this baby that made me realize how evil
I was how evil that I was supporting and
I became instantly pro-life now I
advocate pro-life a college where I
study which is overwhelmingly
left-leaning I also used to be a
socialist because I thought it was
unfair there were people driving
Ferraris in the same place in which
there were homeless starving I am by now
realized that there's a lot of personal
decisions that both of these people took
that brought them to where they are now
after noticing that I was wrong and
socialism and abortion I really wondered
in what else I was wrong I started
listening to ben shapiro more often and
seeing his debates and it turned out
that all the points he was making
sounded kind of rough but it was common
sense later on I discovered you through
the daily wire and since I was by then a
conservative atheist I agreed with
virtually all your points but religion
despite being raised the Catholic
Christians Christian every time you
talked about religion I was like nah I
will take the moral lesson from this
since it is correct but I will not
attribute it to God nor religion a year
ago I became a conservative I was wrong
and every single opinion I had two years
ago when I was left leaning everything
the only thing I wasn't really able to
believe in was God but I agreed in
everything else with you but I said to
myself since I had been wrong and
virtually everything else I will assume
I was wrong as well in God's existence I
am willing to open myself to that
possibility I joined a Bible study group
at college and started reading the Bible
I started praying and now I'm getting
some courage to start going to church I
can't say I believe in God by now
because I'm still uncertain but I am
living my life as if God were real since
I have been wrong and everything else do
you think what I am doing since I am NOT
certain about God's existence is wrong
do you think this kind of resembles
Pascal's wager and if it does do you
disagree since I know you don't like
that argument an atheist argument that I
heard you addressing is who created God
if everything has a creator and nothing
exists on its own this is an argument
that I used to make when I was atheist
fully convinced that God was not real
however I didn't really understand your
explanation and I would like to ask if
you could elaborate a little bit more on
that one or on simple words and then a
bit more complicated to get the general
idea
assuming that God exists God bless you
Matt I say that from the bottom of my
heart there's so many people that see
you as a role model as the father they
never had well and you have brought so
many people from the deepest holes of
depression consider me one of them
thank you god bless you and your family
hope the surgery went well and you're
not in too much pain okay Chris well
thanks for that email and for your
intellectual consistency and courage to
radically change your position like that
to be willing and I think a lot of
people don't understand this or
appreciate this to be willing to even
consider the possibility that you're
wrong not just about one issue but about
as you say almost everything that takes
an enormous amount of courage and most
people don't have it and there are a lot
of people I think conservative
Christians who are basically right about
most of the things that they think but
they didn't earn those opinions really
or come to those conclusions on their
own they were just born into it which is
which is fine I mean I'm trying to raise
my kids that way but so it's good you
know we want to raise our kids that way
that means that they were raised the
right way in my opinion but it does mean
that you know I think and I'm the same
way I was born into these at least most
of these conclusions and I had to kind
of but I had to take all them and put
them to the test and say are these act
yes this is what this is what I was
taught this is how I was raised but I
doesn't mean it's true it's quite
possible to be raised the wrong way or
to be told the wrong things growing up
and so I had to take all these points of
view and subject them to scrutiny and
there are there are some things where I
decided you know no I was wrong about
that and I had to change but the point
is to to come up against the possibility
that you're wrong on such a fundamental
level is a scary thing most people
aren't willing to consider it so I just
you know I
I think we need to appreciate the
courage there it's very very
inspirational
to your question about are you doing the
wrong thing by going to church and
exploring religion even though you don't
believe in God the answer to that is
absolutely not now I have when I talk
about Pascal's wager I've said that I
don't think that's an effective argument
on its own in and of itself to convince
someone to be a Christian but I think
what you're doing here is not Pascal's
wager what you're doing here is you're
exploring the possibility of God's
existence you're exploring religion
you're opening yourself up to that truth
and that is again a brave courageous
thing to do
I fully encourage you to continue on
that path and to keep asking questions
and if you come up against a question
about God that doesn't make sense to you
then keep exploring it and keep asking
don't just don't just put it to the side
and say yeah it doesn't matter because
it doesn't matter and so that's what
you're doing here with this question
about who made God it's a good question
so let me try to take another crack at
it
the answer is that nobody made God okay
I mean that's that's the answer
obviously that has to be the answer for
a theist because if somebody or
something made God then that person or
that thing would be God and the being
that we call God would be just a very
powerful created being maybe you know
much like an angel or something but not
God so in order for it to be God and
then this has to be an uncreated being
sort of by definition one way or another
if there is a God at all you you you
must reach a point an endpoint you must
reach an uncreated creator an uncaused
cause part of the basic argument for
God's existence is precisely that such a
being must logically exist because there
seemed to be only three other options
aside from God if we're trying to figure
out you know
how is it that things exist at all
where'd all this come from why is there
something rather than nothing you know
the classic question
well the theists have an answer but if
you don't want to go with the theists
answer it seems to me that there are
only three possibilities one is that we
live in the midst of a never-ending
never beginning chain of causes you
could trace the effects back and every
effect will have a cause but the chain
of cause and effect would go on forever
into the past never reaching a starting
point so that's one possibility that
excludes God but it seems that that
option doesn't really make sense because
the whole world all of reality in that
case becomes kind of like a man lifting
himself into the air by grabbing his
feet if you could imagine a guy bending
over and grabbing his feet and lifting
himself into the air of course that's
impossible a chain of causes and effects
that is not itself caused by anything
would seem to be like that would seem to
be like like a you know just a thing
that's sort of just hovering in the air
unsupported by anything it doesn't
really make any sense moreover there's a
logical problem with the idea of an
infinite past because if the past is
infinite then that would mean that you
would need to traverse an infinite
series of moments in order to reach our
current moment which means that you
would never reach it because you cannot
traverse infinity so in other words if
the past is infinite we would never have
arrived at right now the fact that we're
at a right now in the middle of you know
time a series of events would seem to
suggest that there's a beginning to that
series if there was no beginning then we
would never get to right now so just the
whole idea doesn't make sense it creates
out just a lot of logical contradictions
and I think that doesn't work the other
option is that the universe did begin to
exist at a certain point but for no
reason it just popped into being one day
with no cause but I think that doesn't
work because then you
in effect with nothing causing the
effect and that is a logical
impossibility moreover if we lived in a
reality where uncaused causes are
possible then why don't we see them
happening why don't we observe that
atheists will use this argument in the
other direction they'll say well if we
live in a reality created by God then
why don't we see the reality of God
around us why don't why don't we see him
why don't we see that why isn't it more
obvious to us and now I would argue that
we do see evidence of God around us but
I would also say that I can throw that
right back at the Atheist and say look
if if things can just pop into the air
with no cause if there can be uncaused
effects then we should see that but we
don't see that all we see around us all
we have ever observed is that every
effect must have a cause we don't live
in a reality where elephants can just
materialize out of thin air or where a
car or something could just disappear
one we don't live in a reality like that
and you would think that we would if
reality itself just popped into being
one day with no cause the third option
aside from God is that the universe did
have a beginning and it was caused but
not by God I don't see how that could be
the case either I see a lot of logical
problems with the idea of mindless
energy or particles just randomly
causing an universe to come into being
not to mention where did that energy or
those particles come from so you still
run into the same problem but I think
the biggest problem with the idea of a
mindless cause is this conversation
right now or really what what allows us
to have this conversation which is the
mind and we have minds we are conscious
beings
how could mindless particles arrange
themselves in such a way as to create
consciousness as to create awareness
how could mindless particles formulate
so that they could become aware of
themselves you see it just it just it
doesn't make sense and that is a mystery
that no scientist has ever been able to
solve and I think because in order to
make a mind you need a mind and that's
what leads us to God that's what leads
us to the conclusion that there must be
an uncaused mind in the universe a spark
that starts the fireworks a conscious
spark so when I say that God is uncaused
that nobody created him that's not a
cop-out that's the whole point I think
we could a lot logically arrive at the
conclusion that such a being must exist
so why is there a God because there must
be a God and why is God uncreated
because he must be uncreated by
definition I think it's a logical
necessity is maybe the best way to put
it all right but I don't know hopefully
that that helped in some way thank you
again for the email oh this is from Bree
says dear Matt I don't think I read this
email yet I or did I don't know I don't
well we'll do it again if I did dear
Matt huge fan of the show I'm a big
believer that that the pro-life position
should not be focused just on abortion
we as Pro lifers should be pro-life in
all situations but I have trouble
applying this to the topic of euthanasia
I absolutely think it's horrible to
euthanize children or people who have
alcoholism or depression like they do in
Europe but what about someone who's on
the verge of death anyway with terminal
cancer or a similar diagnosis isn't it
compassionate to put them out of their
misery rather than force them to
continue being in being in unthinkable
pain dying slowly I just can't see it as
equally bad as abortion to allow someone
who's dying anyway and in pain to just
get it over with I think that's probably
what I would want in that situation
myself I'm interested in your thoughts
great another great question I would say
that it's great that you're wrestling
with this with this problem first I
would say that I don't think the kind of
euthanasia you describe is as bad as
abortion
I think it's fundamentally evil and so
in some ways it's pointless to rank them
but you know I mean shop shoplifting and
rape are also both evil but we wouldn't
say that they're the same degree of evil
so I think that euthanasia and abortion
are both evil both very evil but if we
are going to get into the game of
ranking them I would say abortion is
worse so to speak but why should we
oppose the kind of euthanasia that
you're talking about and just assuming
that you know as we both do that you
know of course it's wrong to euthanize
children or people who aren't terminally
ill as they do in fact do in Europe but
what about euthanizing people who are
terminally ill the very elderly and so
on I think there are three reasons why
it's wrong number one or at least I'll
say it's there are three reasons why I
oppose it okay number one is that I
think it's just inherently wrong number
two I think it's a slippery slope
and number three it is a dangerous
misuse of the medical profession and now
let me go through and explain those each
in more detail number one it's
fundamentally wrong I believe that life
is meant to be lived you know it's
really as simple as that in some ways
every moment of life is precious even
moments that are filled with pain even
the final moments and to take our own
life or to assist someone and taking
their life is to deny the very purpose
of life it is to literally give up on
existence and I don't think that that is
ever the right thing to do
I think we are meant to live our lives
for as long as they are given us to live
number two it's a slippery slope you
mentioned those horrible cases in in
Europe of people being euthanized not
for terminal illnesses but for
alcoholism or depression or what have
you
well how do you think that Europe got to
that point they did just dive in with
lethal injections for alcoholics they
started with terminally ill adults and
eventually they ended up where they are
today
and I think that's inevitable because
the point the justification of
euthanasia is that nobody should be
forced to continue existing and if
someone thinks that life is pointless
and too painful they should be provided
and exit and that has to be the
justification for euthanasia but if that
is the justification then how do you
justify excluding the non terminally ill
I think that exclusion is kind of
arbitrary I mean to be in physical pain
the kind of physical pain you would be
in if you were dying of cancer is I mean
it's it's horrendous but there is also
emotional and psychological pain that
that is that is very much horrendous
itself and so if we're saying that pain
is a is a a moral justification for
euthanasia then I just don't see how you
do exclude those who are in emotional or
psychological pain as well so I think it
it's a slippery sober than three it's a
it's a perversion of the medical
profession here's the thing even if I
thought that suicide could be morally
acceptable sometimes which I don't but
if I did I I still would never agree
with enlisting doctors to kill patients
under any circumstance that is just the
opposite of what a doctor is meant to do
and it creates this kind of this kind of
Jekyll and Hyde scenario where a doctor
is tasked with preserving life in one
case and ending it in another and I know
that it's already like that with
abortion but we don't need to make it
worse the medical profession the chief
aim of the medical profession must
always be to preserve life it's in the
Hippocratic oath
once its aim becomes preserving life or
ending it I think you have literally
destroyed the medical profession and you
have replaced it with something else you
have turned the medical profession into
something other than the medical
profession and I think that's a very
dangerous thing so those are my reasons
for opposing euthanasia I guess I would
also add a quick fourth reason which is
that I just kind of related to the third
reason so maybe 3a or 3b it's it's I
don't I don't see the point of it it's
completely pointless because again if
even if I agreed that suicide can be
justified which I reiterate I don't but
if I did I mean why do you need a doctor
to come in and kill you it just it
doesn't make any sense there are there
are not to be crude about it but there
there are at home ways of doing it so
this whole idea that we need that we
need the medical establishment to work
on the project of killing people it's
just it it doesn't make any sense to me
you know there are in many states there
are laws against suicide and I think
that those laws are good because part of
what those laws do is they allow you
know if someone attempts suicide they
allow potentially you know the the court
system to send those people to you know
just admit those people to mental you
know institutions and that sort of thing
which i think is good but of course at
the end of the day if someone actually
succeeds in committing suicide you you
can't punish them for it and you also
can't preemptively prevent someone from
from doing so
unless they have announced their
intention and then and then you could
get them some help but if someone is
really intent on killing themselves you
can't really stop them they can do it
which is just yet another reason why it
just it doesn't make any sense
why we need a you need to have a doctor
come in and give someone a pill or give
them a lethal injection
you know the whole thing to me is uh
it's just grotesque and wrong and for
the third time a horrible misuse of the
medical profession all right I guess we
will leave it there thanks everybody for
listening thanks for watching
god speed today on the Ben Shapiro show
the media looked to stifle big tech and
forced them to crack down on
conservatives that's today on the bench
Shapiro show